Medical technology has two tiers -- we can
fix that, or we can't fix that.
Spinal cord injuries might soon be on the
good list.
Hey everybody, I'm Trace and you're plugged
in to DNews -- When human nerves are damaged,
they don't regenerate.
Regeneration is different from healing.
Healing leaves scars, but regeneration returns
the tissue to the pre-injured state.
We're relatively low on the regenerative scale
-- our skin, toes, fingers, ribs, liver, pancreas,
kidneys, and smooth muscles are all able to
heal or regenerate.
Nerves, neurons, skeletal muscles and the
heart all grow to a certain size and stop.
Some of the most devastating injuries involve
long-term trauma and paralyzation of these
non-regenerative tissues.
When nerves in the spinal cord are severed,
the brain's commands never reach the muscle.
It's like losing power to your house because
of a downed power line during a storm, but
in humans, we didn't USED to be able to put
that line back up... what if we could now?
Lower vertebrates like the sea lamprey have
regenerative nerves and spinal cords.
Why do THEY get all the luck?!
Their brains are itty bitty!
Well, it has to do with a growth factor affecting
reticulospinal neuron cells in their brain
stem.
The cells transmit messages on movement, and
when University of Missouri researchers hit
the cells with a natural molecule called cyclic
AMP -- the cells would begin to grow!
Cells which were already growing ignored the
cyclic AMP!
No side effects!
Researchers have been looking for factors
like this which appear in humans as well,
hoping we've GOT them, but our DNA had switched
them off for some reason.
A study in Nature Communications found just
that!
A protein called P300/CBP-associated factor
(PCAF) seems to kick off the regeneration
in mice.
With this discovery, we might be able to regrow
nerve cells in human peripheral nervous systems.
When researchers introduced PCAF, epigenetic
factors switched on the regeneration mechanisms
in the cells causing 30% of the nerves to
grow back!
Epigenetics, for those who don't know, is
a process that can switch genes in the body
on and off without altering actual DNA strands.
This discovery is one more step on the way
to regrowing spinal cords after injury, but
it's only part of the battle...
ANOTHER study in the The Journal of Neuroscience
released this week uses gene therapy to fight
spinal injury.
Researchers knew the enzyme (kon-droit-en-ase)
chondroitinase ABC (ChABC) will digest scar
tissue on nerves, but administering it to
the spine was very painful and the enzyme
dissipated quickly -- so repeated treatments
were necessary.
So they taught the cells to produce their
own using gene therapy!
Gene therapy involves injecting a reprogrammed
retrovirus into the spinal cord cells to alter
cellular DNA -- in this case, it programmed
the spinal cord to release ChABC itself!
Thus, with only ONE INJECTION of ChABC, the
cells began to produce their own.
The study was done in rats and TWELVE DAYS
LATER they were up and walking around, with
scar-free spinal cords.
Sounds like a miracle, but it's just science.
Let's get this in humans, okay?
How do you feel about this?
Excited for the future?
Tell us below and subscribe for more awesome
stories about your world, every day of the
week.
Come find us on Twitter if you have questions!